okay good
afternoon let's resume our committee
meeting now with the next uh and last
point in the agenda today the exchange
of views on the failure of Silicon
Valley Bank and the implications for
financial stability in Europe with uh
Jose Manuel Campa chair of the European
banking Authority and Andrea Andrea
chair of the supervisory Board of the
ECB so I want to welcome them both and
thank them for their availability to
discuss this topic with us and you know
all the implications of the svb failure
on financial stability in Europe This
follows last week's plenary debate we
had a debate on the same issue on
Wednesday March 15 where married
McGinnis European commissioner for
financial services financial stability
and capital markets Union said that the
EU should stay alert after this collapse
as you know U.S authorities shut down
Silicon Valley Bank on Friday March 10th
2023 as the as a vvb had its core
headquarter in California and was the
16th largest bank in the U.S catering
for the financial needs of technology
companies globally the collapse of uh of
this bank is the largest failure of a
U.S Bank since the financial crisis in
2008 over all three Banks svb silvergate
and signature failed due to liquidity
problems as they run out of cash to pay
back deposits
SBB had invested in a long-dated U.S
government bonds which lost value when
the Federal Reserve increased the
interest rates to combat inflation
when svb started selling bonds to pay
back deposits and announced on March 8 a
US Dollars 1.75 billion Capital increase
to cover the losses caused by the sale
of its loss making Bond portfolio it
took just 48 hours between the time it
disclosed that it had soldered the
assets and its collapse the U.S FDIC
ensures deposits of amounts up to 250
000 US Dollars however the FDIC received
exceptional authorization from the
treasury to announce that all depositors
would have full access to their funds in
the aftermath of the collapse European
Banks shares fell heavily today we would
like to hear from you more on the impact
of these events on the financial
stability in the EU and the
repercussions on the EU banking sector
Mr Andrea you have now the floor for an
introductory statement of five minutes
and then it will be followed by the
introductory statement of Mr Tampa of
another five minutes
thank you very much Madam chair the
failure of some mid-sized U.S
institutions several this month remind
us that specific features of bank's
business model can make its balance
sheet particularly vulnerable to
interest rate risk in extreme cases this
can turn Rising interest rates from a
boost to profits into an existential
threat in this context the case of
Silicon Valley Bank is particularly
Illuminating the institution
concentrated both its Landing activities
and its deposit taking activities among
Venture Capital firms fintechs and
startups more than 80 percent of its
deposit base consisted of an insured
corporate deposits which tend to be more
mobile than other deposit types most of
the bank's assets consisted of fixed
income securities which typically lose
value when interest rates rise as
deposits outflow started mounting
Silicon Valley Bank liquidative fixed
income securities at a loss further
exacerbate in the runways deposits and
the strain on its liquidity these happen
in a U.S regulatory context where
mid-sized Banks like Silicon Valley Bank
are Exempted from or treaty
preferentially under relevant Prudential
standards such as liquidity requirements
the LCR and the nsfr and capital
requirements
such banks are subject to less frequent
stress tests than larger ones and they
can be allowed not to reflect in their
regulatory Capital they are realized
losses of Securities held in the balance
sheet as available for sale
the episodes under consideration have
been contained also by The Prompt and
forceful intervention of the U.S
authorities which are committed to
protect the old initial and ensure
deposits of the banks involved under
what is known as the systemic risk
exception and set up a central bank
liquidity facility accepted from Banks
fixed income securities valued at par
there is no Direct Read across of the
U.S events to euros significant Banks
first and foremost this is because the
banks we supervise do not exhibit the
outlier features of extreme interest
rate risk and predominant Reliance on
concentrated uninsured deposit base
which might be termed the svb business
model our banks generally operate with a
more Diversified constitute customer
base although and ensure the policies
are an important source of funding in
the URL as well they tend to be more
relevant for business models which are
well Diversified or both the asset side
and the liabilities side including their
deposit base
importantly all our banks are subject to
the LCR and the nsfr requirements
liquidity coverage ratio have only
decreased marginally since the monetary
policy normalization process began and
they averaged in excess of 160 percent
towards the end of last year
more than half of the existing buffers
of oil liquid assets are made up of cash
and Central Bank Reserves which sensibly
mitigates the risk of Mart to Market
losses when liquidity needs their eyes
in fact the recent data indicate that
those banks that have experienced some
deposit outflows appear to have
succeeded in maintaining their level of
excess liquidity they've done so mostly
by issuing debt Securities and reducing
interbank lending and only to a minimal
extent by liquidating securities
the sector's overall liquidity
resilience also results from the
overhaul of the regulatory framework
implemented in the aftermath of the
global financial crisis and the choice
made by the European Union and the
European Parliament in particular to
apply the international standards to all
the banks operating in its jurisdiction
we're well aware that the ongoing
fast-paced normalization monetary policy
conditions is increasing our bank's
exposures to interest rate risk we
started assessing interest rate risk and
crazy spread risks as early as the
second half of 2021 when the first signs
of inflationary pressures emerged and in
2022 we enclosed those risks in our
supervisory priorities last year we
repeatedly measured the sector's
response to standard 200 basis points
shocked to interest rates highlighting
that the net effect on Bank
profitability and Capital is expected to
remain positive under the Baseline
macroeconomic scenarios
the Boost interest margins give to net
interest income as a positive impact on
banks earnings capacity
the effect this is expected to
outweighed the costs associated with
worsening asset quality as borrowers
find it more difficult to pay back their
loans
at the same time we also reviewed the
interest rate increase spread risk
management practices of the most exposed
Banks and instructed them to improve the
way they monitor and manage the negative
impact the rising race typically have on
their economic value of equity that is
the net present value of their economic
world
of their balance sheet when interest
rate rise the economic value of equity
Falls due among other factors to the
reduction on value of fixed income
securities including sovereign debt
securities
this happens irrespective of whether
Banks measure the value of such
Securities at amortized cost or at
market prices for reporting purposes
if not appropriately managed and edged
and realized losses on Securities that
Banks hold that amortized cost might
become a concern particularly because
investors and sophisticated depositors
tend to focus on Market values when
their level of confidence dwindles on
the back of changes in fundamentals or
even mere rumors
during this review of risk management
practices we ask that some banks to be
more conservative on their assumptions
and when the assumptions they apply when
stress tests increase stress on
financial securities we also encourage
them to improve the calibration
validation and back testing of their
asset and liability management models to
make sure that these models properly
reflect the law repayment and deposit
withdrawals behaviors by customers in
life with a new interest rate
environment liquidity funding risks have
also been upgraded in our set of
supervisory priorities as the
normalization of monetary policy started
and the phasing out of the extraordinary
Central Banking funding facilities came
closer our supervisors began in the
second half of last year to devote
significant attention to the
sustainability of the bank's funding
plans
both your airbanks and supervisors are
therefore focusing on the risks and risk
management practices that are most
relevant given the fast pace of change
in the interest rate environment
the market turmoil triggered by the
failure of the U.S banks have been
further aggravated by the significant
drop in share prices and spiking trade
the full swap spreads experienced by
crazy Swiss last week
while you're at a bank saw their share
price is stumble their funding and
liquidity positions were not materially
affected reflecting the continued
resilience of the sector
is a globally systemically important
Banks engage in a complexity focusing of
its business model was already subject
to significant liquidity outflows in the
last quarter of 2022 in order to restore
trust the Swiss authorities provided
Credit Suisse with a large volume of
liquidity support and the details of the
bank's acquisition by UBS were finalized
over the weekend the ECB has issued a
statement welcoming this outcome and we
are clarifying in a joint statement of
the single resolution board and the EBA
that the hierarchy of claims is clearly
defined in our resolution framework and
City one Capital would always be first
of third losses and would be fully
written down before additional tier one
instruments could be written down this
approach has been consistently applied
in past cases and we will continue to
guide the actions of the SRB and the ECB
Supervision in all crisis interventions
thank you
so very much now give the floor to Jose
Manuel camp
thank you chair and honorable members of
this Committee of the European
Parliament thank you for this timely
invitation to exchange our views
in the past days we have been confronted
with events that have great concerns on
the health of Banks and increased
volatility in financial markets first it
was disguised there were bank failures
in the U.S these bank failures were
idiosyncratic in their business models
and affected U.S banks with only limited
exposure to European banking sector a
very concentrated client base with large
uninsured the processor has been
described a lack of proper risk
management have paved the way for the
liquidity challenges that morphed into
sovereignty concerns leading ultimately
inclusive resolution by the U.S
authorities
uncertainty remains on the situations on
Regional banks in the U.S with proposals
from the private and public sector to
provide liquidity support in an attempt
to stabilize the positive flows for
certain Regional Banks
then there was last week the situation
with credit sues where here a prologue
restructuring of the bank that have led
that have had repeated risk management
failures made markets and investors lose
confidence
two years ago producers had already lost
5.5 billion dollars during their cellos
collapse and other issues including
green seal exposures in their funds and
a weekend franchise was losing customers
raising concerns on his viability over
the million turn which materialized over
the weekend
those failures heed at times of height
and uncertainty and geopolitical risk in
the macro context and major societal
transformation in response to the energy
crisis and to climate change needs as
monetary policies changing course there
is no time for complacency over the past
decades we have faced low interest rates
now with the gradual increasing rates
Banks were beneficiaries in the short
run of these inclusion rates their
profitability increase last year as net
interest income and interest margins
gains materialized throughout the year
but on the other hand as we warned an
increasing interest rates have impacted
also valuation of financial assets and
expectations of potential deterioration
of credit quality going forward will
continue Bank deposits have also become
more sensitive to interest rate
differences and become successful
sorry susceptible to be moved at short
notice
particularly with the increased
digitalization and instant communication
that may easily accelerate the Quest for
the passage yields across the world
these issues raised questions on the
viability of some business models over
the last two weeks and adding a pinch of
uncertainty and financial instability
that made them reinforce a downward
spiral and overall trust therefore all
banks I think regardless of size and
complexity need to manage this new
environment with in which Rising
interest rates and increased volatility
is key to their macro Outlook at this
point in time we're confident that more
than a decade of War has put the EU
banking system in a better situation to
address these challenges banks have
better capital and liquidity positions
the rewarded framework and the single
rulebook has added a layer of resilience
to the system and enhanced supervision
and governance provides also better risk
management
the Eubank is sector today shows Capital
ratios and level ratios that stand at
Comfort levels with a collective tier
one ratio fully loaded of above 50 and
11 ratio also fully loaded 5.5
EU Banks lastly exceed the minimum
liquidity requirements as stipulated by
the LCR and the NSR ratios and at the
ABA were closely coordinated and monitor
the situation exchange views with our
POS members whatever needed to assess
the situation the single rule book also
provides a robust regulatory framework
the comprehensive application of the
Basel framework wall Banks operating in
the EU further ensures the resilience of
the European regulatory framework in
particular as was already mentioned by
Andrea the basal standards on liquidity
rates the LCR and sfr have been fully
implemented both as an individual and
consolid level in the EU Banks these
contracts with the US were International
regulatory standards only only apply to
the most significant important Banks as
we have learned with sbv with Silicon
Valley Bank even the failure of a less
significant Bank could trigger a crisis
of confidence with knock-on effects to
other Banks and this shows that
completing the regulatory package with
the timeline loyal civilization Dazzle
package it's important from my
perspective
enhanced supervision and governance also
by Banks has put us in a better position
to assess risks in a more
forward-looking manner for instance the
sensitivity of bag to changes in the
interest rates has been in the focus of
EU regulators and supervisors for over a
year we at the ABA we published a
comprehensive regulatory package on the
management of interest rate risk in the
banking book last fall and increase the
risk utility of the way banks are
managing this risk by loud sugar new
quantitative impact study on this issue
earlier this year as mentioned also by
Andrea the ACB banking supervision
performer review last year of the
interest rate and credits papers
management practices on the significant
institutions in the Euro area
we're currently in the middle of
Performing the ABA stress test exercise
that hopefully will provide further
evidence on the resilience of the larger
banks in the union we have increased
coverage for this exercise in a number
of banks included 70 Banks compared to
the previous exercise which only
included 50 banks in 2021 and would use
particularly severe assumptions in the
adverse scenario the adverse scenario
puts Banks to the test of high and
persistent inflation and interest rates
and a Severe GDP contraction it also
enhances the sexual decomposition of the
scenario to more reliably stress the
credit portfolios of banks this is
stress tests that focus on solvency
concerns and should provide additional
quality and resilience of banks in
another scenario
recent crisis showed that despite having
enhanced Banks capital and legal
positions having a strength and
Regulation and enhanced supervision bank
failures and lack of confidence may
still take place in the system we
therefore need to remain Vigilant and
not be complacent I would say three
takes aways for policy Bakers and
Regulators from the development of the
last weeks first upholding the
confidence in a historical regulatory
framework requires as I mentioned before
to complete the pending regulatory
packages we have to implement Basel 3
standards fully Time game Faithfully the
completion for me also of the other
pending legislative files such as the
AML packets will Foster Market
confidence by providing better
supervision and enhancing also the scope
of supervision to new areas and new
players such as in areas such as crime
operation in the financial sector and I
think that would also encounter
resilience second as is well known the
European banking sector remains
fragmental of national lines and there
is no rationale for Europe to keep the
banking Union resting into pillars only
proper risk and capital allocation need
the foundation of a common Deposit
Insurance scheme crisis management work
that also needs to be a strength to
reduce fragmentation and Divergence
across the Union finally likewise the
Capital Market Union remains incomplete
both of these large progress made proper
translation from political ambition into
reality to prepare our economy for
potential more volatile times to come
but more important also to address the
finding needs of our future economic
growth we will continue to monitor the
bands and we start ready to provide that
expertise going forward thank you very
much for the invitation and I look
forward to your comments
start our q a session and we start with
Marcus Ferber for EPP
thank you very much if you don't mind
I'm going to speak my mother tongue and
with the collapse of the Silicon Valley
Bank we've seen uh the rapid increase in
interest rates uh can be a problem for
banks you've just explained that as well
but uh
We've often talked about uh interest
rates in a different connotation and
with a different approach because in the
stress test in the past it was at the
lower for longer scenario so what would
happen if the interest rates were low
for the long term now we have exactly
the opposite happening and because the
ECB increases about 300 350 basis points
and then a further 50 basic points and
as announced by uh president Lagarde so
I think the question is whether or not
uh you were looking at the wrong risk
and to what extent are you looking at
interest risk and uh
uh there was a very rapid reaction to
the Silicon Valley Bank to calm the
markets it was agreed uh that that the
guarantee in the uh a U.S 250 000 so
that no one would have to be worried
about their deposit so I have two
questions do you think that the way that
the American authorities proceeded is
correct is are there risk with this
moral hazard for instance and uh if uh
they're going beyond the limits and
secondly would that be possible in the
EU or do you think
um that goes against the no creditor
worse off principle uh and the question
is to both of course thank you
I'll start first on the issue of the
stress tests
that you address as you are absolutely
right that this is a scenario the first
scenario in a long time then which we
are considering a macro environment of
increased interest rates increases
spreads which also have happened in the
past and some fixed income outcomes and
the impact that that increased scenario
of interest rates are so more higher
persistent inflation and lower economic
growth
I think that will provide us good
insights going forward I think that the
scenario is qualitatively different from
all the previous ones but at the same
time it's been it's been I was going to
say accused but it's been referenced by
many of the of The Observers and the
banks involved was the toughest scenario
ever by the ABA and I think that's
probably right what we meet when we when
we measure in terms of the
GDP drop under the adverse scenario
relative to the Baseline
um it's a difficult scenario I think
that that will help us and provide more
robustness on the situation of the banks
most of the impacts come obviously
through the deterioration of credit
portfolios from the deterioration of
economic Outlook or higher cost of
lending on one part and the other one
from the iteration of the market
portfolio as assets our adjustments are
taking place as a result of the
representatives rate those those
valuation effects which is part of what
we're seeing right now actually quite
large on our stress so we're confident
that that stress should have should we
have fallen providing some input uh on
the spot on the area of you mentioned
the the issue of the public guarantee of
the extension of the deposit Insurance
in the U.S Beyond 250
000 to all depositors this is a clause
that by understanding I think Andrea
explained that his initial remarks as
well it can be called upon the U.S
authorities under the specific provision
for preserving Financial stability and
in the current context of the EU we do
not have that course and obviously as
you said there are concerns about that
type of action going forward in terms of
moral hazard and other aspects about
what Will does it mean then to to
provide some skin in the game for
parties for people participating in the
different banks and Market monitoring
very quickly because you covered it all
the first point I want to say is that
the fact that we didn't have in the past
the stress test focus on increased
interest rate but it was more low for
longer scenario doesn't mean that from
the supervisory perspective interest
rate risk was not covered we started
already in 2021 to look into uh interest
rate risk in the banking book in
particular we are being regularly
applying
these uh standard let's say shocks which
are also dictated by the EBA guidelines
and bad Baza standards of 200 Business
points in all possible directions so
parallel shifts the tilting of the yield
curve is steep any of the yield curve
and we always identified banks that were
performing you know Wars under these
scenarios and ask them to strengthen
Edge or strengthen their risk management
capacity so there has been quite a lot
of focus on interest rate risk and on
the point on the a guarantee of deposits
I would say that again the issue is
sometimes we always have the impression
that we have to you know map what is
being done in other countries also in
our jurisdiction I would argue that the
best protection for uh against these
type of events is to prevent the type of
extreme business models that we have
seen being very fragile in this
efficient with concentrated
uninsured the post-based homogeneous in
terms of business lines all fintech
venture capital investors uh crypto
asset providers that behaved in a also
in a coordinated manner in this case and
you know extreme interest rate resource
in terms of the asset and liability
measure so these I think in terms of
supervision is the most important
priority thank you
thank you very much now I give the float
a full tank for snd
thank you Irena thank you chair and
thank you Mr Andrea for being here
and also for your first spoken
contribution that's very impressive as a
dense it's good to hear that that's you
uh
a very serious in addressing the the
risks
including interest rate risk and among
Madison doing the stress testing
that's good to hear I hope also the
deposit holders of the banks will find
your story as impressive as I do because
what I find striking in this situation
is that it's mainly it's revolving
around unsecured deposits
if you look at Fork the Silicon Valley
Bank but also Credit Suisse they have
very Diversified business model for a
different business model
where Silicon Valley Bank had tech
companies as Credit Suisse had high
wealth individuals but they started to
run because unsecured deposits are the
most mobile right so this is what they
have what what they have in common
so I was wondering what is the situation
then in Europe because I can learn that
in the US about 40 of the deposits at
the at the bank are unsecured
but I see that the the guarantee is in
the U.S is higher and the U.S relies
Less on banks so is it true could it
then be true to conclude that unsecured
deposits in Europe are higher than for
example in the US
is that a situation
and do you see this as a vulnerability
in the system because we can refer to
Edith but that's up to 100 000 in the US
there is a guarantee up to 250 000 and
even then
uh you see Bank runs appearing
so how do you see uh the see the
situation is this
phenomenon that we uh that we that we
that we need to address as well that the
fact that our unsecured deposits and the
deposit holders try to run
thank you very much for your question uh
well um
let me say first of all uh
let's see
the first point I want to make is that
even in this period of turmoil the
liability side of the significant
institution of the European Banks has
remained very stable so this means that
at the moment we do have a strong Trust
of depositors in European Banks which we
think is well placed
um
this is not only an issue of uh you know
the is also an issue of the structure of
the liabilities of European Banks as I
mentioned let's say we do have indeed
quite some Reliance on initial deposits
also in the also in the U
um but let's say the um the the the
business models especially the the uh
the business models which have more
Reliance on uninsured deposits are also
more Diversified so they have not
concentrated uh uninsured depositors
they have more spread different types
corporate financial institutions public
administrations and they have a better
diversification also on the other side
and the smaller mid-size banks in
generally in general are uh CA a a
higher weight of stickier retail insured
deposits in there in their deposit base
so these are important features another
important element is that in the U.S
traditionally the U.S are are a
marketing which of course Capital Market
activities are more developed and we
have money market funds which are being
very aggressive also in their
competition for uh Bank deposits there
are two
developments recently in the US which
have driven this volatility of deposits
the first one is that the FED has
reintroduced the supplementary leverage
ratio for the largest banks which means
that Banks started to you know uh
avoiding Gathering additional deposits
because this would have inflated their
balance sheet excessively at the same
time the the FED has introduced a very
as
provided very favorable conditions on an
overnight reverse repo facility that
made very easy for the money market
funds to invest without
counterparticulate risk at very good
return so the money market funds have
become very competitive so there has
been a major acceleration of the
outflows from deposits to money market
funds this is not something which at the
moment we are seeing in the in the
European Union
so in general there are different
structures in the in the markets and
different structures the bank's
liabilities that I think make these type
of events uh less less likely but in any
case let's say again I think that our uh
our institution set up is fit for
purpose that's my assessment at least
I've moved
very very short comment on the fact that
I agree with all the assessments that
then Maria has made on the structure of
the banking sector but also very much
with his analogy to the U.S situation
with the money market facts I think
something that has potentially changed
and that we're monitoring very carefully
as we're moving into this High interest
rate environment is that over the last
decade of loan interest rates there's
been digitalization there's been social
media there's been other means by which
information can be spread and within
those information on the spread part of
the experience of the last two weeks
it's also a potential lack of confidence
and potential
elasticity of deposits to move away and
that's one area of sensitivity we have
been in the laboratory frame we've
always been prudent
in Europe about what the assumptions are
about potential you know
withdrawal of deposits in terms of the
calculation liquidity ratios at the
corporate level at the written level but
that's an area in which we need to
continue to to be prudent and you know
for instance we assumed in the stress
test that the pastor of interest rates
to deposits so that the banks will have
to pay on the on deposits is 75 for
corporate deposits and 50 for rental
deposits which is much much higher than
what the evidence suggests but it's
another product measure so I think that
bar will need to be original
thank you thank you very much and I'll
give the flow to Stephanie jankutong
president
thank you very much Madam chair thank
you Mr Andrea Mr kampa the collapse of
the Silicon Valley Bank raises a number
of questions about the stability of our
banking system in Europe
who were aware that a number of public
authorities when you repeated this
including the ECB have already come out
uh
make clear statements about the
resilience of our banking sector but
nevertheless this bankruptcy will have
effects on other banks in the United
States
as you say we need to stay very Vigilant
when it comes to any potential contagion
effect when it comes to our European
Banks if the this contagion were to take
place in the EU to what extent uh
European National supervisors ready to
react
how does that fit together with your
role as the European banking Authority
and ECB in terms of responding
as for the important financial
institutions what are the points that
you're looking at the of course they'll
be similar to the ones with the
medium-sized Banks but I'd be interested
to hear about that and then what about
the national European supervisors
efforts to maintain the competitiveness
of certain sectors and think
particularly if someone's medium-sized
companies and tech companies the case of
the Silicon Valley Bank affected
European tech companies as well
is the European response sufficient to
preserve these sectors
thank you for your question on the on
your first uh Point uh
well we know that uh
banking institutions by constructions
are highly leveraged and relying on and
do uh transformation of liquid
liabilities into more liquid long-term
assets so by construction there is uh
there is a liquidity risk and interest
rate risk in the in the banking sector
that might generate also contagion this
is something that that that that that we
know how do we react I mean in general
of course the best reaction is to
prevent this to be triggered in the
first place so to make sure that these
risks liquidity risks and an interest
rate risk are managed effectively by the
Banks so
um that's the first thing we look at so
as I was saying before we started very
early looking into the interest rate
risk management by the Banks and into
the funding plans of the banks the focus
on funding plans is particularly import
and when the interest rate environment
shifts no because Banks where accustomed
basically to rely on very cheap funding
from Central Banking facilities and now
of course this this source of funding is
trying is drying up so they need to
develop their funding plans they need to
do so conservatively and we have been
very challenged in this respect let me
say also that being the banking unit
helps because
this enables us Whenever there is uh you
know there are banks with similar
business models no we can read across
and do peer comparisons across Banks
which are you know facing the same type
of risk identify strength and weaknesses
and you know push the banks to adopt the
best practices in the market on the
effect on tech companies uh let's say we
are aware we have also heard that some
tech companies actually added exposures
for instance two Silicon Valley Bank
they had the deposits in Silicon Valley
Banks so there have been a a channel in
the European banking sector via
exposures to these tech companies but I
think that the European banks have been
able to easily support these tech
companies to face this liquidity
strength thank you
thank you very much now I give the floor
to Claude grufa for the greens
thank you chair good afternoon to both
our speakers
thank you for coming sharing your
analysis of the potential consequence of
the
um failure of the Silicon Valley Bank
and the other uh two banks on the
European financial sector
in order to avoid such a situation in
Europe we have to uh uh avoid uh
avoid is happening here and we know that
since 2008 now a couple of questions the
SVP
um vulnerabilities
um weren't anticipated by the bank or
its supervisors largely because of the
regulatory exemptions that it benefited
from
due to the um previous president Trump's
uh reforms
it seems that it wasn't subject to a
stress test and
the ECB recently launched its stress
test for 2023
um and it seems that uh the tests are
less strong than some of those that are
currently underway do you think that
this scenario that's been invested is
sufficiently demanding and do you plan
to carry out
um additional tests to ensure the
resilience of the European banking
sector secondly a lot of commentators
have said that the svb was subject
oh sorry if the bank had been subject to
uh Basel III requirements it wouldn't
have gone under do you think that the
this event should lead us to reconsider
deviations that we're currently seeing
in the transposition of bezel 3
agreements in Europe and then finally
what lessons should we be learning from
this case
and also that of uh Cody Swiss
were the principle of no creditor worse
off was not respected because the
um
bondholders are undergoing more debt
than shareholders
are you going to take that into
consideration in your upcoming uh risk
management system thank you
thank you thank you for your questions
uh if I may on the on the issue of the
of the scenario the adverse scenario for
this stress test that we're running
right now
as as I mentioned my initial remarks I
think that this scenario Beyond The
Narrative of higher interest rates and
higher spreads and the impact that those
High interest rates will have on
economic growth and economic activity on
the level of interest rates themselves I
think we're confident that both the
level of interest rates are sufficiently
stressed to test certainly beyond the
current economic outlook for for
interest rates the the numbers are on
the base case are obviously the
projections that the ECB had at the time
of the launch of the scenario which was
at the end of last year but on the
adverse case it's significantly much
larger than what looks to be low the
Outlook going forward on the spot rates
are very demanding on top of that
there's also increased on Credit Express
on a number of other Securities
particularly fixed income securities and
as I mentioned before there's also
significant adjustment on the evolution
of certain asset prices particularly
commercial real estate residential real
estate and equities so I have confidence
that the scenario will be sufficiently
severe in that aspect in terms of your
question about deviations from Battle 3
as I mentioned minus of remarks I think
with the EBA we've been consistently
saying that we want to stick to
International rules that we want to
should remain loyal to the
implementation of battle rules within
the European Union and not just loyal in
his content but also in his timeline you
know so I think it's important that we
go forward with the timely
implementation as close as possible at
the basil agreement with the muscle
agreement we are state in the past are
concerned with some of the deviations
and particularly with the likelihood
that the possibility that some
transitional Arrangements may become
more temporary so I think in that sense
the current episode as you mentioned the
fact that the rules are applied to a
large number of banks has also shown the
value that that has in terms of the
strength and probation
a last Point regarding the the
issue of the no credit Wars of the
situation of Credit Suisse as it was
displaced but Andrea and I communicate a
joint communicate with the secret
resolution board yesterday we believe
that under the current regulatory regime
in Europe you know 81s should bear
losses after core Equity tier one has
been has per basically 100 of their of
their value
but
maybe one small adult what Jose Manuel
said
I need to be careful here because I
don't want to say but let's say there I
don't want to say that this happened in
the case of specific Banks we are
talking about but there could be
sometimes the um Temptation not to look
um
favorably to uh banks financial
institutions which are
invest in particularly new technologies
in new instruments and to experiment you
know with the uh with these uh with this
sort of new uh Innovative instruments
and there could be the temptation to say
okay to let these models flourish unless
maybe make the uh the regulatory
supervisory requirements for these Banks
a little bit less demanding
I mean I think I'm very supportive I
think that we need to let our banks also
invest in new technologies they need to
do so I want to have new uh fintech
companies becoming Banks and maybe
challenging the incumbents but if you
are a bank you need to be a regulated
and supervisors bank and you need to be
strict in the application of the
requirements and I think this is an
important principle that we need to keep
in our in our let's say let's say in our
attitude towards supervision going
forward thank you
thank you thank you very much now give
the floor to Gunner back for ID
thank you very much Mr camper Mr Andrea
I've got two questions to both of you
first of all
svb
failed
and it was one of the most important
lenders to Tech starters now through the
engeu billions are being invested in
tech companies as a future Market but
what happens if the tech bubble bursts
the svb does not seem to have been one
of the most profitable and successful
banks in the world so how does the ECB
in the EPA model the kind of risks of
the bursting of a technology bubble
secondly svb
and Credit Suisse was run by political
correctness and incompetence the svb's
chief administrative officer Joseph
Gentile
was a CFO Layman Brothers until it went
down in 2008. there was also involved by
uh Arthur Anderson which is the
accounting firm that was wound up after
the Enron crisis the CEO
rushed off with his private jet to
Hawaii after having sold off all of his
svb shares just before the uh bank went
under
so we urgently need
a discussion on the impunity of these
banksters
so that this does not repeat itself in
Europe
what have you done specifically since
the financial crisis and the Eurozone
crisis to ensure that our Savers
pensioners and investors are safe from
incompetent managers
and ensure that they are ultimately
accountable for their actions thank you
just I think part of the regulatory
framework that has been built over the
last decade has made a what I would say
a fair amount of progress in trying to
enhance both
the methodologies that we have under
regulation that we have on governance on
freedom proper assessments on making
sure that the the members of the
management body and the exact body are
assessed properly I think their
challenges are still there and and I
think as we go through the crd we might
want to enhance that process a little
bit
but also beyond that we also align risk
objectives in a better Manner and go
with compensation of particular formal
assessments so now we have a
compensation requirements in the
European Union that put limits on the
rest of fixed immigration versus
variable remuneration on the amount of
variable remuneration that should be
received also linked to uh or live with
shareholder incentives May link to stock
performance on delayed payment of some
of the variable remuneration over a
number of years depending on the
seniority of the institutions and as
well as the possibility of having Clorox
or maluses to be applied in situations
which exposed there is bad outcomes for
the institutions that they manage so
that some of that delay remuneration can
be blowbacks those are mechanisms that's
in there in place and actually have been
already imposed in some cases in the
European Union uh I think in the past
when I think for instance on the
resolution of popular I think it was on
callback some of the compensation that
was taken there's some we do have some
mechanisms that hopefully will help
align with incentives and enhance better
governance of the institutions
foreign
Tech bubble I know whether we have a
tech bubble but let's say in general the
the the the the main issue the main uh
contribution that we can give to uh any
development of bubbles is to uh make
sure that the uh crateries controls are
in the proper place at the banks and
that Banks do not inflate these type of
bubbles by relaxing lending standards
towards certain type of uh certain type
of counterparts and I can tell you that
in the last years in particular starting
during the pandemic we've been very very
alert to look at the sectors that were
particularly risky no because maybe they
were hit by the pandemic or because they
were uh uh you know uh hit by the energy
shock or any other type of events and we
have done quite granular and in-depth
analysis of the risk controls of the
bank's vis-a-vis Expo
let me say that you say how can we be
safe from incompetent managers I mean
the most important let's say protection
that safeguard that we have is the
freedom property
and here is the vetting by the
supervisor of the professional capacity
the skills the uh the the knowledge uh
but also let's say the I would say the
uh ethical Compass no of uh of uh of
Bankers so uh we we know you have the
banking package on your table we have uh
strongly argued in favor of a strong
let's say uh uh and harmonize and fully
harmonize the framework for fit and
proper that could enable the supervisor
in all member state so you know the
banking Union uh to do uh demanding
excellent assessment of the um of the
managers and members members of the
board and ensuring competence and
professional skills across the board
also with diversity of professional
regimes we need to have robust challenge
in the board we are doing this era
review of board Effectiveness which
means the ability of the board to really
challenge the management and they have
checks and balances within the work of
the banks I think that's the most
important Safeguard thank you
okay thank you uh very much now I give
the floor to mikhil Hugo fan for ACR
thank you chair and thank you Mr Andrea
and Mr kampa for coming to the European
Parliament uh things have moved very
quickly from the failure of the Silicon
Valley Bank and I initially thought I
would ask you some questions specific to
the failure of svb but then we were all
concerned about Credit Suisse last week
and over the weekend
and while svb and Credit Suisse are not
directly compared or related to each
other I do think we see some overlap
the key reasons why both ultimately
failed include three main reasons and
the first is
failure at the board of these companies
incompetent and failed leadership uh
where svb was guessing too long on these
low interest rates while there were
clear indications that these interest
rates were going to rise and obviously
created Swiss with Mo involved in
multiple scandals and the the second uh
reason is is multiple missions and
failures by The Regulators the svb was
already on the list of many analysts as
a potential risk and and Credit Suisse
was already seen for a long time as a
car crash moving in slow motion
and the third the third item I would
like to address and I think that's also
very important to address at this
hearing is the failure at the top of our
own policy makers and public
institutions
who have continued to pursue free money
and Reckless spending policies for more
than a decade that is the root cause for
the 40-year high inflation we're facing
right now and the sharpest rise in
interest rates we are seeing in more
than 30 years
and we know that tackling inflation
seldomly goes with a soft Landing
so in a matter of a couple of short
weeks we have gone from a U.S Bank
catering to startups uh
coming to a threat of a potential
financial crisis in the EU
and my question is then relating to such
potential crisis
my question to you is given the
information available today what risks
do you imagine the failure of svb and
the acquisition of Credit Suisse to have
on the European housing market
how will this news affect European
citizens ability to acquire loans
and what about the willingness of banks
to open credit lines to businesses and
consumers do you foresee potential
underlying inflation caused by this
crisis hurting potential homeowners in
the short or medium term thank you
foreign
our assessment so far and obviously it's
been two weeks since the since the
terminal of the last two but in terms of
what's the impact has been in lending
activity and availability of credit
across the board of the European Union
is that we have not seen really at this
stage any significant concern so when
you come when you're concerned about
what is the impact of these in terms of
lending to households or to smes I would
say that at this stage baby is too early
to judge but I would be I would be
prudent on saying that there was any
there's any evidence right now that
there is any impact on that aspect it is
fair to say that with a risk assessment
when we think about the European Union
uh a credit markers right now one of the
areas of risk concern as we're going
forward that we had the monitoring was
real estate markets overall mortgage
mortgages particularly commercial real
estate and household real estate in some
parts of the Union but in terms of
additional provisional potential credit
Crunch and here obviously the supervisor
has much more intense up-to-date daily
information but my impression is that
there's no significant impact on credit
provision
I mean I wouldn't tell a lot I mean in
terms of the uh tightening of monetary
policy what we are seeing is that let's
say the developments are so far
according to the expectation so in as
the tightening has started we had seen a
continued growth of loans until Q3
basically of last year then in Q4 the
the the bank lending survey of the ecbs
started highlighting a tightening of
lending standards so Banks were
expecting to uh let's say Titan lending
standards apply uh you know
higher interest rates to customers and
being more selective which is what the
transmission Channel monetary policy is
is about at the moment this is
proceeding in an orderly in an orderly
way as I said in terms of the impact I
mean Jose Manuel said it already in
terms of the impact on the housing
Market we have been doing already last
year a a targeted review and then on
site campaigns of inspections on
exposures to commercial real estate
identifying of course where there were
problems in terms of evaluation of the
collateral in terms of origination
standards in terms of credit risk
management and we are now repeating the
same campaign of onset inspection the
same targeted review or residential real
estate it's clear that when you are
moving from a low interest rate
environment to a say to higher interest
rates these are markets that could go
under greater under greater pressure so
you need to make sure that banks are
there credit risk monitoring in the
right place that when they see signs of
deterioration on the side of the
customers they preemptively get in touch
with the customers trying to restructure
the loan trying to make you know to
address the problems as early as
possible this is the and also the last
crisis and we are trying to apply all
the best practices that we have
identified in order to follow closely
the development of great risk in these
markets
foreign
to Chris McManus for the left
uh thank you chair and I suppose an
offload this talk about uh Bank collapse
as you know worries us all and it does
really concern many people who remember
how talk about thanks far far away being
a difficulty turned into a a very real
and brutal austerity for for millions of
people and of course we all hope that
what we're dealing with here is to some
extent an isolated incident of course
but we do need to be uh Vigilant uh I I
recently became aware of what I would
call
in hindsight now particularly badly
timed report that was commissioned by
the European banking Federation from
earlier this year and in the forward the
evf states when they were looking at why
U.S banks are so much more profitable
and I quote the Regulatory and
supervisory pressure EU banks are
exposed to play important roles and that
and if I record again Financial
regulation has a direct impact on the
banking sector's ability to support the
real economy
so it was all
uh basically saying that regulation was
bad now my question to our two
contributors or rather an invite comment
is
is it their opinion that the Euro system
and the EBA should prioritize Financial
stability and protection of the taxpayer
above any other political agenda and
would they agree
that to even suggest rolling back
regulation should be given quite short
shift and that any loosening of
Regulation most certainly should not be
on the agenda and a second query
um not immediately related but svb was a
lender to many tech companies and it was
also connected to the world of uh crypto
assets and I'd ask what analysis have
our contributors got or what they
consider carrying out into how
vulnerable European Banks might might be
20 further crypto collapses and what
would be your advice to any EU Bank
tempted to invest in such assets thank
you chair
so although
do you ask on the question of how the
interrelationship that some of these
failures particularly in the US have
have with the crypto markets I think
that's a that's an interesting part that
we need to assess and assess carefully
because it is true that there were a
large
because of their specialization with
high-tech firms there was a large
exposure of some of the of the crypto
industry to to these Banks and otherwise
on their way around I think their
lessons there to be learned and
fortunately in Europe we have the Mika
regulation that we're now in the process
of of starting to implement once it has
been approved by the legislators I hope
uh we are going to uh I hope we will
implement it properly and to say
we are assessing precisely you know what
is the relationship of this particularly
when we think about some of this crypto
assets as being payment devices similar
to e-money institutions and whether the
proper regulation that should be
considering to them in terms of the
reserve requirements for those reserve
requirements should be put forward and
what's the Prudential make sure there
should be a relative Square on the early
stages of developing the Royal technical
standard Journey with espa in this
process but I think that's actually some
lessons that we need to assess going
forward it's a it's an important aspect
uh as I said I think we're in a better
starting position that the us because we
have Mika in place and overall I think
that's a better position as you know in
terms of the second part of your
question what should be the the attitude
that we have uh or other the approach
that we have about Banks all these type
of assets are approached so far has
always been that these other assets that
are difficult to understand in terms of
their underlying business model for many
of them that are highly volatile so the
banks should be very prudent in Holiday
we recommended not to hold them and at
the same time also not to Market them to
potential customers in their advisory
work
Basel has moved forward without use with
with some principles and standards on
how to include
some of these crypto assets into the
banks balance sheet in Prudential
standards there was some agreement that
was reached in December and you know
some area which when as we go forward in
Europe we may want we need to consider
the translated and implementing which
basically distinguished between two
types of crypto assets you know crypto
assets are backed by good assets the
score will broadly the faint as stable
currencies or stable crypto assets
another ones that are not back up
they're more speculative in the second
case the treatment overall should be
basically a deduction if banks wants to
invest on those taxes in the first one
depending on the characteristics of the
assets and qualities that the treatment
maybe some were more favorable but
that's the progress that has been made
in that part
for me a couple of wars on the European
banking Federation report I mean it um
I mean I would like to take more time
but I don't want to be I it's
interesting no because basically what
the European banking Federation report
did was to compare the capital ratios of
European Banks and U.S banks and the
conclusion was that we were
tougher than than our U.S colleagues
and uh and these walls basically a
competitive disadvantage for our backs
now so that was the nutshell the main I
mean this this when I first read it I I
thought I mean this doesn't resonate
with me I mean we meet uh frequently
with our colleagues at the fed and we
compare let's say uh the capital ratios
the treatment of our large Banks and uh
my perception has always been that we
are in the same ballpark in terms of
capital ratios the UK being a bit higher
because they rely more on the uh
counter-cyclical macro Prudential
buffers then then we do
um
then digging a bit deeper into the
analysis you understand that they take
all the European the Euro area
significant institution so 113 Banks
right now and the larger sample of the
U.S banks so while indeed on the global
G6 let's say the global systemically
important Banks we are basically in the
same ballpark as our U.S colleagues or
maybe even a bit lighter than our U.S
colleagues it is true that we are much
more demanding in terms of capital for
the uh for the banks of lower lower size
so the the U.S have done a very
dichotomic approach they were very
demanding in terms of buffers for the uh
for the um especially through the Seeker
the stress test for the largest banks
but much less so for the lower Banks and
to some extent what we have been
discussing today is also reflecting
these bifurcated approach that they that
they adopted
the other comment the other points on in
the report let's say that we are
excessively heavy-handed as a supervisor
you I I I tend to disagree as you can
imagine with these comments but of
course let's say we also have to take
some positives let's say and
we might uh I mean it is it might be
true that we in terms of procedures
let's say we can we can be a bit lighter
sometimes we are also thinking on how to
become lighter on procedural but
definitely not on stand us and not on
the intrusiveness on the uh rigor of our
of our supervision on this I don't think
that there is anything that need to
change thank you
okay thank you very much now give the
photos
thank you chair I will continue in in
Spanish
thank you to uh Mr Andrea for being here
today
as I said previously uh on the 10th of
March we saw the biggest um
uh banking failure uh since uh the uh
Washington in the United States now
fortunately the repercussions for our
markets have not been uh similar to
those that we saw with Lehman Brothers
nonetheless
the intangible effect that it meant have
on our content continent is that we have
finally realized that the union bank and
the banking Union sorry hasn't been uh
completed 11 years after it was started
only two out of the three uh pillars uh
would be ready to act if something
similar were to happen as what happened
in America
if
there were to be a um parallel uh
banking crisis as well as National
deposit systems that would uh lead to uh
stumbling blocks of member states and so
I'd like to know what more
do we need to happen before we can make
progress are there any technical issues
that aren't allowing us
to complete the banking Union
um beyond the political issues that we
know
um are is it going to take a crisis for
us to finally solve this finally uh
European smes are finally uh are more
dependent on the banking system than the
bigger companies
um 70 of smes are dependent on uh their
banking funds uh unlike 40 in America
where they're much less dependent
um the European smes have a much worse
conditions uh for their banking
financing as well so
um
they have a set number of tools um
that they need to be able to use the
Silicon Valley
case shows us that we have to ensure
that our smes are no longer so dependent
on a single source of financing so I'd
like to ask you what are the
perspectives of the European banking
Authority and it in this area and what
can we do to ensure diversification of
financing for our businesses
um from the perspective of your
institution thank you
thank you for the question I think that
uh
I share many of the comments that was
there at the beginning and I think I
mentioned that in part of my points on
the initial remarks I think that we
should remind ourselves that we have an
incomplete banking Union which will
remind ourselves that doesn't complete
back in Union has implications in the
short term for a function of the single
Market that is
not integrated as a result of that leads
to fragmentation that that fragmentation
also leads to limits in resharing and
also to difficulties obviously in
facility growth potentially the medium
long term
we have put forward a number of
suggestions in the idea that that the
banking unions should continue I think
is it's not just a banking Union as I
say my initial Market is the
complementarity of the capital markets
Union as you mentioned as well on your
additional remarks on your question uh
regarding the ability the availability
of different alternative sources of
funding for smaller media Enterprises
and for Equity Investments going forward
is an important aspect and I can only
encourage that we continue to work in
that direction
I mean let me add one point to what Jose
Manuel said
um
they say we do we do manage crisis and
we can continue managing crisis without
edius without the complete maging here
so we don't have a dysfunctional regime
the point is that
let's say the wind which we do that is
very complicated I mean we every time
and this has been the experience in
recent cases no in spare Bank also not a
liquidation case but still an exit from
the market RCB in Cyprus in any case we
have to come we are confronted with
different features of the national
regime so if you compare the European
Union with the banking Union with the US
no we do have
the same amount of funds if you take
together the single resolution fund and
the national deposit guarantee schemes
we are in the same ballpark as the FDIC
in the U.S no but it's very difficult
for us to deploy this funding to
actually
ensure a smooth management of the crisis
because we have in any case different
regimes at the national level different
uh
engagement of the deposit guarantee
scheme so what is crucial in a crisis is
the funding and and having a more
integrative system would make our life
much easier and I dare say also the life
of you know Savers depositors and
citizens thanks
thank you very much and I'll give the
floor to mark belka
High inflation
which is in my opinion increasingly
homegrown
requires
higher interest rates and higher
interest rates
have consequences for the financial
stability something that we have
overlooked so far slightly at least
so the question uh first to Jose
the recent experience
will will they prompt the discussion
to about our regulatory regime and what
I have in mind is number one the
Eternal problem the over-dependence of
commercial banks in Europe on uh on
domestic domestic Sovereign papers
and second
which surfaced in one of the cases in
America
it's the uh
maturity mismatch between
liabilities and assets uh
do we need some kind of deepened
discussion on this baby
strengthening of the regulatory regime
although I hesitate to
to to propose any any anything like this
so this this was this was for Manuel for
Jose Manuel camper uh
two short questions for
Andrea Andrea uh does the recent
experience and and the
uh
the consequences of increasing High
increasing interest rates
have any impact on the functioning of
TPI may be surprising uh
surprising link but well now we we maybe
uh forced to take into account Financial
stability risks in assessing
you remember countries which makes the
whole process even more complicated
and the third question also for Andrea
Andrea do you see potential spillover
effects of the right of the rate Heights
in the Eurozone for non-neuro countries
thank you thank you for the question
so on the question that you addressed to
me on the issues particularly on the
high interest rate environment and do we
need an enhancement of the regulatory
framework particularly the area of it is
very risk in the banking book
uh the solid exposures particularly the
the the home bias of the Solan exposures
I would say here you know that obviously
this is part of a long discussion but uh
on the interest rate risk of the banking
book as I said in the initial remarks
and we'll be monitoring as well in some
uh and some always been
discussing some of the responses this is
being an area of enhanced monitoring and
we put forward a package of regulatory
of technical standards and guidelines in
October that take into account the Super
Mario buyer test to take into account
prudent regulations in terms of you know
what the assumptions that we put about
deposit outflow like I mentioned earlier
and other aspects of the of the
management of the interest rate of the
Viking book on the banks on top of that
we put forward a quantitative assessment
at the beginning of this year we had
done an impact assessment before we put
we we report for returning a standards
to assess to assess the value but given
that the industries are rising faster
and maybe even higher than expected you
know where to do a new imperative
assessment and we're in the middle of
doing that right now in the aspect of
the
Sovereign Holdings I think that that
this is obviously is being a continuous
to be an area of concern our view has
always been that it's better to have
these portfolios managed according to
the risk that they have implicit no not
at face value and beyond that also the
probably some some concentration
concentration charges or limits maybe a
good way forward because at the end when
we think particularly about the banking
Union you know it's not the same to have
a portfolio of a given size of certain
amounts of whatever the size is of 200.
of sovereign bonds of your area member
countries of those 200 are from a single
member country or from all 27 member
countries the interest rate risk
diversification of that is probably the
same because they're all subject to the
same interest rates a monetary policy
which is the ECB but the diversification
aspect of that portfolio is quite
different depending always on one single
National Bond or national member State
versus a diversified portfolio so I
think that encouraging the
diversification would be good also for
the bank engineer
yeah
thank you well uh of course I it's
difficult for me to reply on TPI you
know which is on the other Tower of the
of the ECB what I noticed is that let's
say in these uh very fast paced increase
on interest rates that we had since July
last year let's say the spreads between
different uh between different countries
not between different sovereigns have
moved that little even in the turmoil of
the last days this for me is a blessing
because it enables me to focus on the
interest rate risk of banks irrespective
of the flag that they have on their
headquarters and also
in a sense to look into their internal
risk controls more than on the more
General macro macro environment so I
hope that these Remains the case
the issue of
um I think also however let's say the
the point a point I want to make is that
Banks use
say garment Securities predominantly as
high quality liquid assets now for their
liquidity coverage ration also as a
liquidity buffers to be used in case of
stress
uh these liquidity buffer is correctly
accounted at market value so you need to
uh to uh to look at that market value
but Banks might still have these Assets
in uh accounting books held at amortized
cost
which means that if they actually sell
them they would need to take Capital hit
if they are of course undervalued if
they if they lost the value due to
increase in interest rates so that's a
little bit of a of an issue as I see it
I've been arguing since a long time that
ideally one should have and this is
maybe for you to consider legislation
that says that if you want to account I
know it's a bit technical but it's
important for me if you want to account
something for a quality liquid assets
for the liquidity buffers you need to be
ready to sell this asset in the market
anytime you have a liquidity stress so
maybe you should come from accounting
books that are marked to Market and that
email you would be an important
Improvement in the in the framework on
the spillover effects between Eurozone
no Eurozone
um
but see I I would say I I don't notice
anything in particular unfortunately to
be honest we do have a market a a
banking Market in the banking new which
is still a bit segmented across the
national Lines no so we don't have a lot
of pooling of liquidity or uh massive
you know uh
management of of of
uh a cross-sold banking Union so these
Dynamics uh remain a bit natural so you
see countries in which you have a huge
spike in interest rates you see a huge
increase in in in interest margins and
in profitability you would expect that
in a banking Union you would see you
know Dynamics by means of which maybe
other Banks start entering that market
there is more competition these are
actually dynamics that unfortunately we
do not see so there is very much uh
National Dynamics but I don't see
spillover effects of course there could
be some spillovers in terms of risk if
the risk management is not done properly
but let's say the interest rate risk in
cross-border groups is deeply integrated
so I don't see a problem from that side
thank you okay now we have only five
minutes left and I have three requests
for uh catch the eye so I suggest we
collect the three questions and then I
give you the floor for the uh answers
otherwise we will not make it and I
would like to give the opportunity to
all the three requests
thank you very much Iran and thanks
August for very good uh discussion uh
you know I'm going back to interest rate
risk because silicon value Bank this was
kind of classical banking failure from
Old Time suffering which interest rate
risk and refinancing risk and I'm
grateful that you are talking about
using of stress tests quite a lot I
guess it's very helpful tool obviously
in refinancing risk it's more
complicated but going to my question I'm
referring to what Marek was talking
about due to really substantial increase
of long-term rates somewhere in
financial system there is substantial
loss on Mark to market value on Long
bonds because there is huge amounts of
long bonds or fixed fixed term the fixed
rate long-term assets so I wonder if we
are really confident that we know how
much is in the banking system and how
much is elsewhere because this was an i
i very appreciate what Mr Andrea just
said a few few minutes ago this is this
is some of the concerns there is huge
amount of
of uh Mark to Market losses because the
yield went up like 200 or in case of U.S
300 basis points so if you multiply by
duration of long-term bonds these are
substantial money so my question is EV I
have this risk under control thank you
thank you chair uh let me go back to the
problem I see it as a problem variable
interest rates uh mortgage rates
specifically uh we talked about that Mr
Campbell with you last year I think but
in these times of uh you know
stagflationally precious and
uncertainties related to the war in
Ukraine uh there could be developments
in the markets uh uh you know collateral
values real estate values and some
segments of the Union could be falling
down uh would you see uh especially
since missionary is here that this could
be a problem not only for the mortgage
takers but also for the banks as was the
case I think with the with the subprime
mortgages back in the US in the in the
in the previous crisis so there is this
asymmetry of Prudential supervision
which is whereas rulebook SSM Etc but
there is nothing on the European level
as far as the a business conduct
supervision and especially uh you know
consumer protection and mortgages is
concerned would you think that this uh
you know would be would take a more
regular approach from us from you from
others that there would be no interest
rate transfer into mortgage takers
because I think this is a problem
remains a problem at kumbater to
realizing some problems for the banks as
well thank you
thank you madam chair
I find this discussion that we had today
very interesting for one more reason
the fact that it's taking place we
somewhat relief
but that is something I want to get you
a response on it
completion of the banking Union and it
is
taking in consideration
the fact that the decision of the U.S
regulatory authorities
to step in
and safeguard
or deposits not only those covered by
FDIC but all deposits
including the non-guaranteed deposits
which by the way are more than 250 000
US dollars my question is very simple
are there any lessons to be drawn for us
in the Eurozone regarding the deposit
system and my second question
how would you respond
to a cypriot depositor in 2013
unfortunately suffer
through a very vicious deposit haircut
thus size of the banking Union matters
after all
thank you and I would expect you are
Frank response
so thank you before giving back the
floor to our speakers let me remind that
we have 10 minutes extra interpretation
so we can allow for you know to conclude
and have all the answers and I want to
thank the interpreters for the
availability
thank you thank you for the questions uh
if I met first student mayor on the
issue of your absolutely right that the
way and Andrea media reference to this
as well with the accounting has been
down of the positions of fixing a
portfolios engineering the banks is
different depending on the business
model the purpose of that it's also true
the banks need to manage interest rate
risk in the books on Huawei with the
managed interest rate risks by acquiring
fixed income security so it's important
to look at the assessment overall
of the sensitivity of the bank's
business model not just in their
positions to the to the to the
industrial movement and that's why
there's been so much stuff has been done
on industry risk on the banking book I
think uh and and well that's implied for
liquidity Banks would in general many of
the assets that they hold to maturity
the purpose is precisely to do the
interest rate with management and to
understand that they would not need it
for a liquidity uh stress it's likely to
maintain in the books so it's likely to
be good until the uh until until the
payments are due on those on those
Securities and the mark to market
performance is less relevant but
nevertheless it's an area which we
Monitor and the supervisors as well
monitor very close closely Mr jelliness
I think you your question is is it was
well taken I think that the area of
consumer protection is an area which we
can enhance overall at the European
Union we have actually we're doing
uh a peer review on a particular area of
consumer protection which is how the
company authorities assess the consumer
protection authorities assess the the
behavior of the treatment of customers
and their arrears and what banks actions
are taking in the different in the
different uh countries will have the
outcome of that in the next month so we
have to share that with you I hope
that's a step will work going forward
are mandate engineering consumer
protection obviously as an EBA is much
much more weaker than the Mandate that
we have on Prudential purposes on the
last question as we discussed at the
beginning on the issue of the positive
thing that the actions taken by the Euro
by the U.S authorities is possible
within their tools it's an issue that
races
significant concerns of moral hassle
going forward but at the same time it's
an issue that I think is less relevant
for many business models in the European
Union because the the extreme situation
of the business model of the bank that
was interviewing where there was 94 of
the password that was unsecure
it has such experiences now present in
the current European at least across the
significant institutions in the current
Universal European Banks so it's like
unlikely that it would be a similar
situation taking place
foreign
on the point of
multi-market value let's say I said what
I think no on the on the liquidity
buffers
let me um
let me say also that let's say in
general I don't like uh the terminalized
losses not because it gives the
impression that something is hidden
under the carpet no end is not visible
actually banks are requested to do a
pillar three disclosure so if you go to
their books you can see exactly how much
the market valuations of these assets
would be and how much would be the
impact on their on their Capital
positions so there is something that is
that is in the in the open and indeed
let's again if you take our banks many
of them have their liquidity buffer
which is composed for more than 50
percent of cash and uh
deposits Reserves at the central bank
and also in a sense they could go a long
way before having to realize these
losses so and if they keep these uh
these Assets in their balance sheets
until maturity there wouldn't be any
loss at the end at the end of the day so
let's say the issue is is uh say we
shouldn't overemphasize the issue that
there are huge Market losses hidden in
the bank's balances this is not the case
first of all they're not hidden and
second let's say the composition of the
of the buffers as such that they can go
quite a long way before having to sell
um let's say assets and realize these
losses but still I think you have a
point in the same as I mentioned before
we should make sure that you know at
least what we asked them to hold to be
dealing with the market stress needs to
be carried at market value because they
need to be ready to move to sell it at
any moment without getting a capital hit
on the on the point or I mean on the
point of mortgages and conduct Jose
Manuel has already replied let me
reiterate that we are conducting
a specific thematic review or
residential real estate or mortgages and
again looking at the bank's practices
their risk management we don't look at
the contact but indeed let's say we also
see if there are improper refinancing or
you know type of behaviors that are not
compatible with the sound that is
management practices and we would
definitely raise these issues to uh to
our banks on the point on Ed send the
safeguards of deposits again as Jose
Manuel also say that in the first of all
the best safeguard for depositors is to
make sure that they have no reason to
run so that we don't have business
models which are extremely uh
you know exposed to some to some risks
and in general I don't think that we
should you know change the the framework
that we have that we have right now so I
know that the the air Cuts applied on
cypro depositors in in the past have
been particularly harmful we see still
today no supervising cyber Banks how
much you know inducing volatility in the
potential behavior of the posters can
destabilize the banking sector so I
think that when these tools are applied
you need also to always to be very wary
and careful about the consequence that
this could could cause in future so
that's a very delicate topic and we are
very much aware of of of this issue
thank you
thank you very much now we have
concluded our public hearing I really
want to thank all the participants and
in particular our guest speakers
for their availability their frankness
and I think this is also an important
signal that in situations like these the
parliament is the house also of
transparency and we let everybody know
and we inform the citizens thank you
very much have a nice evening